hey guys it's Justine and this is Carly
hi how are you I'm so good I'm so
excited to finally be doing a video
together guys we've been planning this
it feels like honestly for two years
like it might actually be two years date
schedules you travel a lot I'm always
traveling and finally we are here we
also shot something super fun for your
channel doing a film about it we shot a
video series that I'm so excited to be
launching it's about women in stem and
using their science skills and really
creative cool industries and gaming is
an industry that I'm so fascinated by
and you are such a pro and we just got
to talk to just seen about it so anyway
that's a long way of saying tune into
this series and yeah so fun I love it we
even played some Call of Duty together
and this was super second time you play
Call of Duty at my house in your entire
life oh so this is the second time I've
ever played Call of Duty I was I I'm
really bad I might be the last time I
play it's okay it's alright it was
definitely a really tough game to get
into especially just not ever playing
before now in that theme of Call of Duty
you guys know that my favorite color
color combination is camouflage and I've
always wanted to do this cake so it too
celebrates we're gonna try to make a
camouflage cake which is what what does
that even mean to you like do you
envision all of the colors like
different kind of circles or colors on
top of colors I've a feeling it's
getting a messy yeah probably I'm gonna
take my rings off do you think that's a
good idea yeah sometimes things get to
be I love to bake and so this is really
exciting really I love to bake I love I
love the science of baking and I love
actually like making cakes and you did
all the hard work for us because you
know it takes a lot of time so here we
go this looks good you stood all right
they came from the box
well I mean three of us because we're
gonna make this all layered will just
flop this down here do you want to cut
off the top of one of those otherwise um
yes put me to work here okay here you go
before we started Carly was like so
what's the plan I'm like you know what
girl
usually these baking videos I have no
plan whatsoever that's part of the fun
how do you find baking do you find it
like do you it takes patience it does I
feel like if I'm not doing it for camera
it's kind of relaxing but what I'm
filming video is about baking and stuff
like that it gets a little stressful
because we're trying to make sure we're
filming in and getting the shots there
we go the garbage cake you are so funny
I love you just used to box cake
yup nothing wrong with the back
especially if we're mostly about the
decorating do you have like a favorite
like baked good did you like to make I
am all about
I love making cookies but I love cakes I
mean I learned how to read by like
baking and and yeah oh you have my gram
and I used to always make these things
called shitty cake because you basically
just add water
and you get like it's probably full of
chemicals and really not organic
whatsoever or vegan or gluten-free okay
so this doesn't have to be perfect it
looks good so now we're gonna like slap
on some of I guess am i singing here I
make a mess in your kitchen Oh huge
growth I the things that have happened
in this kitchen it's just if you ever if
you ever as you go I wouldn't suggest
eating this well no cuz you know I
didn't really put that much effort into
how flat do we want this should I make
this perfect you sure like cuz I'm I'm a
bit of a perfectionist is the opposite
think of perfection and then just do the
complete opposite of that that's what we
do here this is just the glue and I kind
of hold it all together so I must say
that I love all the stuff that you're
doing with girls and coding what was the
summer camp like that you did cuz
there's an incredible idea well so we so
I first took a coding class as like a
summer workshop a while back this is
this is gonna be our fourth summer that
we have no difficulty summer camps that
we're teaching girls to code but it all
started because I took a class and I was
absolutely blown away by the fact that
coding is this super like powerful
language that actually builds all the
tech that we all use and you learned how
to code in school right that's honestly
if some of you guys might
know this but that is what really got
this whole passion of creating video
started because I loved creating and at
the time that was what I thought I had
to do to be able to create you doing
like web development stuff like that
yeah this is so much fun but I really
loved sort of the front end a bit of
like design and stuff like that in your
front-end development classes did you
were there a lot of girls or in high
school isn't the single guys because we
didn't really have a front-end class it
was more chest it was just basic it was
basically like just the coding and then
I liked designing no matter so you
seeked out yeah so then I wanted to like
graphic design and video production so
from there kind of crazy just a long
story short here we are now we're
orbiting our banner
it's all full circle well that looks
good do you want to throw it on top of
that yeah but I I told you I'm a
perfectionist like what you already got
like you are a my legging no okay I'm
also gonna eat it as I go okay that's
totally buy it and then we can throw
that one now on top now I learned
something I made a really big mistake on
a previous video that we did and I can
trim the edges to make it even smart and
some things happen so I'm just gonna do
a nice little nice little slice here I
was trying to make this at least a messy
as possible for you cuz know for kidding
me you're the one that is we're in your
home I feel like I'm you know such a all
so happy to be here with you pretty good
cake I'm not gonna lie maybe just hungry
well you guys can take a little to go
I'm not gonna lie I eat a little bit
while we iced oh yeah I usually make
vanilla cake but wow if we just go like
this
mm-hmm just like that just like that but
ah so maybe like plop some of the
different colors around it okay and then
we'll kind of merge them together when
you were growing up did you bake a lot
though
my mom's Dan yeah and usually like I
feel like she I would try to help her
but I think my helping would usually
just make more of a mess so that kind of
I guess probably had carried over into
it I think my adulthood so guys doing
another summer camp this year too so
basically how it all started as I took
this class and I was like whoa this is
crazy coding is something everybody
should know whoa you're quick at this
nicely done my ice a lot of game so I
was like whoa everybody needs to know
how yeah about this how to code and I
did not intend in to build something I I
just kind of wanted to help other people
have like an experience to learn so it's
been it's been really fun - this summer
we have a big summer ahead last summer
we had 300 girls in our camps that we've
gotta cool in cities all across the
country and and yeah it's basic kind of
HTML yeah like Ruby they basically build
they build projects separate a bit and
they're awesome
I'm so proud of them I'm so impressed
that you learned it in school and that
like that did that inspire you in any
way to think about like a career in tech
or even what's weird - because I never
really thought about a career which my
mom always is very worried about well
you got to do something you got to go to
school and I think because they were
very I guess accepting to like the weird
things that I like to do your parents
are awesome very like that they let me
like just do make videos and I get it's
always stealing my dad's video camera
you know but they must be so proud they
are they're great so I definitely owe a
lot of this to them it is just great to
have that knowledge of how things work
even if you're not coding yourself just
to like take a class yeah just to
understand it you know it could open
your eyes to like so many more things
that you might want to be doing
holy cake looking but you're you're like
flying by me I'm kind of just watching
you like this it is all good this is
great we have very different styles so
you're like fast and you get it all done
I'm like no need that I like jamming
yours looks really good I'm just kind of
going for it no you're a sex better and
you're much faster you okay yeah I'm
just filling in the blanks here so what
else is new how's everything how's New
York good New York is freezing cold
that's um
very happy to be out here with you that
looks really good I like pleasantly
surprised yeah I'm just gonna kind of
like merge them together a little bit
I'm mainly just watching you what's your
favorite like old school game like the
first one that you really got excited
about I mean definitely Mario Kart but I
think golden is probably what made me
love first-person shooter games so
that's like I feel like where my love of
it all started really and you've got to
get an attendance which I like you have
to there's a game stop probably right on
your way next place I'm going there's a
Best Buy up the street yeah I want you
to come to what are my Mario Cart pie
I'm so impressed
I love so what are you guys doing so we
basically all just have attention please
on the name didn't get it
my friend had a ten thousand dollar of
Mario Kart tournament we thought what I
was just having a Mario Kart party and
we show up God and he throws down
$10,000 and he's like this is a
tournament of a lifetime and it really
was and I lost unfortunately wait 10 yes
dollars crazy a winner high-stakes go
kart racing there we don't have that in
my house yeah you just have pizza that's
really I think this looks pretty good
wait so you're up see you like three
girls yeah I have three sisters so we're
for girls who exactly did you guys play
together growing out of well my middle
sister no we would always take the TV
and she would get so upset because she
doing when do I get to watch my show and
me and my younger sister should be like
Ninon now you're like and we're taking
over yeah in poor Brienne she's the
middle one the middle lunch the middle
sister I swear there's something about
middle sisters that kind of have to like
fend for yourself because your older
sister and your younger sisters are like
getting all the attention so ministers
Laksha Brian Brian yeah I feel for you
Brian
Carl call me are you good call me yeah
but she's she's I feel like she's our
normal sister where's there's me and my
other sister Jenna and we're just this
is what we're doing you know totally but
it really did create a different job
types - you're creating a career and
then yeah and you're like the face one
of the most prominent faces in
attackable gaming I pretend you know
YouTube I mean this is a whole other
world that I've only recently started
getting into and I was so good not
really that's not true and I started a
channel in the duty of Casey - yes yes
loved it and I have an amazing friend
her name is Anna Laura and she helps me
she helped me start my channel and it's
been like this whole other world that
I'm just so inspired by by the YouTube
community I'm so impressed with the way
that like people really support yeah one
another and and all the YouTube
collaboration videos that and I've seen
you do so many videos with all my
friends and I was like yeah here we are
we're making my Mogambo cake look at
this beautiful it's so cute I mean I you
know I feel like if we had several hours
I probably make it a little bit better
fine for the time being I'm quite
impressed so what it's worth the icing
tastes like I think this looks good with
you thank you so much for coming and
helping me make this delicious candle
cake I you did all the hard work but I'm
just happy to hang out with you and I
was so excited we finally are like we
need to do more we do I know next time
we have some free time which is usually
very rare next time I may get rid of you
I'll let you know come to the colossi
office and we're all we should do we
should make something fun it'll be great
well guys make sure you go check out
Carly's channel I'll put a link in the
description to her too and to where you
can see the video that we shot together
where we played call of duty
thank you
[Music]